[Aplausos]
eu sou casado há quase 35 anos com a
mesma mulher há quatro anos recebi pelo
correio um carnê 36 prestações para
pagar um carro que eu não comprei e quem
recebe esse carro era uma mulher que eu
não conhecia
imaginem a situação minha sem saber
explicar e da minha esposa tentando
descobrir se aquilo ali era realmente um
engano se tinha alguma coisa que eu não
sabia
é claro que de início não enganam mas
quem é essa mulher que conheceu ela
situação muito desagradável né
isso evidentemente era uma fraude e essa
fraude ela acontece porque a forma como
os dados que nós temos em nossas mãos o
jogo da verdade que as empresas têm nas
mãos deles
ela tem uma deficiência crônica existem
pessoas privilegiadas que estão
acessando esses dados de bancos de dados
e podem usá-los de forma indevida
eu fiquei pensando tem que haver algum
tipo de outra oportunidade e essa outra
maneira é o bloco tem eu explicar depois
mas a diferença é a confiança que você
tem nesses dados a confiança de que
esses dados não vão sumir não vão ser
manipulados vão estar disponíveis
assinados pelas pessoas que deveriam ser
assinada
qual é a grande revolução que nós
conhecemos todos da escola
a primeira revolução do conhecimento à
imprensa ela transformou a sociedade
tirando das trevas para uma sociedade do
conhecimento uma grande revolução mudou
o foco de poder e deu a nós uma grande
qualidade de vida e de desenvolvimento
outra grande revolução foi a máquina a
vapor
a máquina combustão a máquina elétrica
tudo que veio junto com essa revolução
da manufatura ou seja antigamente para
fazer um sapato é necessário você ter
uma pessoa que era especializada e que
era capaz de fazer sapato manufaturando
com as mãos com essa revolução isso se
multiplicou de forma muito muito rápida
nós tivemos então uma outra grande
revolução em seguida que foi a revolução
que a internet trouxe em relação à
distância
hoje de pijama eu consigo na minha cama
em casa aqui em são paulo me inscrever
no torneio de celular de ping pong no
alasca consigo verificar uma multa de
trânsito para um amigo na austrália e
consiga enfim reduzir essa distância de
forma dramática
um exemplo que eu gosto de dar é uma
amiga nossa aqui mora no canadá ela sai
do trabalho pega a filha de três anos na
creche e chega em casa e quando percebe
que tá faltando alguma coisa na
geladeira e precisa e na venda
na esquina que ela faz ela liga a
internet coloca a filhinha conversando
com a vovó como contar uma história
entretendo a criança e ela então vai até
a esquina com o que precisa é
impressionante é um bom exemplo de como
as distâncias foram totalmente abreviada
pela internet e um blog também o que
muda
ele muda a forma ea universalização da
informação a confiança que pode ter essa
informação
ela consegue eliminar a censura consegue
eliminar aquelas cela bancos de dados
não está disponível caiu a energia
alguém se aproveitou de dados que não
devia os dados não estão devidamente
autenticados tudo isso deixou de existir
além disso ele manipula os dados de uma
forma automática conforme você queira
junto com isso tem uma tecnologia
chamada smart contratos que é a forma
como esses dados são armazenados cuja
vida se isso é uma revolução disse isso
realmente faz muita diferença
hoje temos que ter um problema que seja
digno de uma revolução
qual é o maior problema da humanidade
hoje uma problema da humanidade hoje é
exatamente a sustentabilidade da vida
neste planeta
nós temos um compromisso com os nossos
netos que deixar esse mundo minimamente
sustentável e esse é o grande problema
que eu acho que o bloco quem vai nos
ajudar a resolver que o petróleo vai
acabar todos sabemos
a pergunta é o que ele vai destruir até
acabar quanto aquecimento global ele vai
trazer quanto lixo ele vai colocar nos
mares nas fazendas nas nossas florestas
etc
essa terra que vocês estão vendo aqui
ela tá sendo cada vez mais destruída
pela ganância e pelo uso indevido dos
recursos naturais
nós temos nesse ponto aqui 1970 o
momento em que essa esse verde que ela
tinha mais recurso renovável do que
demanda do que consumo sendo extrapolado
e desde então essa abertura que é o
grande perigo de consumir mais do que a
terra pode repor
somente entre isso aqui ele assusta isso
aqui é medido em área de terra
agriculturável quanta terra é necessário
para manter um estilo de vida
o estilo de vida por exemplo os
americanos ele está muito escuro aqui
porque ele é muito intenso em consumo de
recursos no brasil mas também não
escapam não estamos no meio do caminho
alguns países africanos esse sim estão
consumindo menos do que a terra dispõe é
conhecida pegada ecológica
existe um outro fator importante que
também é convergente com esses dois
ameaças acabar os recursos não
renováveis é é um excesso de consumo dos
recursos renováveis
mas esses povos aqui que não estão
consumindo tanto estão sendo
bombardeadas para consumir mais então
vai ter mais gente que até hoje não
consome tentando consumir como resolver
isso
como evitar o colapso
o consumo responsável e resposta mas ele
tem um inimigo o inimigo é o marketing
já perceberam que o marketing
ele é muito poderoso ele gasta muito
dinheiro para convencer você a consumir
ele só fala daquilo que ele quer
imagine por exemplo um sabão em pó sabão
em pó que você vê nas imagens da tv
uma mulher com uma roupa gerosa macia
como a criança também toda de branco
andando pela mata é bonita gisele flores
ele não está se mostrando como aquele
sabão em pó foi obtido
qual foi o impacto que ele teve na
natureza nem mostrando qual o impacto
que vai ter paz e depois descartado pela
natureza
esse marketing é muito poderoso na
verdade ele é tão poderoso que ele quase
aniquila o consumo responsável
nós precisamos de algo mais precisamos
de confiança confiança na informação que
nós temos para ser consumido por seus
consumidores responsáveis do shopping
eu não vou explicar nada técnico aqui
tem muita coisa legal tem muita coisa
passou a noite mas o importante é que
eles entendam uma vez colocada a
informação neste grande registro
universal
ninguém tira aquilo de lá são dezenas de
milhares de computadores com cópias
idênticas a menos de dez minutos são
todas iguais
é uma coisa assim que é quase
inacreditável
você tem então cada lançamento que é
feito aqui
o lançamento foi feito aqui ele é
registrado alto indicado monta se um
bloco e esse bloco aqui então passa a
apontar para esse de modo que eu não
consigo mudar nada sem invalidar toda a
cadeia ou seja ele só cresce
o placar no final isso o negócio tão
impressionante que me chamou a atenção
por sua vida
se eu escrevo alguma coisa no bloco
ninguém vai poder mudar isso
aliás ninguém vai poder tirar do ar não
tem o ditador chegar e tirar aquilo
aquilo é uma verdade universal que
ficar por vários anos e me lembrou
quando eu ainda era namorado
falando da minha esposa eu fiz um
mochilão da itália
e como todo jovem
cheguei em pisa a torre inclinada de
pisa naquele tempo eu podia acessar e
subir na torre e subir três andares e
sem que qualquer pessoa visse fui lá com
um pedacinho de de ferro e fiz aquele
coração com as iniciais então e por isso
aqui vai ficar para a eternidade no da
torre de pisa não é verdade
a chuva o vento tirou 40 anos depois
imagino que tenha tirado aqui eu
consegui aqui uma declaração de amor não
dá pra ver agora mas está no bloco j
então isso você eterniza as mensagens
sem censura como funciona o oxigênio
eu vou fazer uma comparação simples
muitos de nós moramos em repúblicas em
alguma situação de comunidade e tem que
registrar então esse essa república
geralmente tem aquele livrinho livre em
cima da mesa né
então vem a primeira lançamento alice
depositou dois mil reais bruno também
depois outro reais
outro morador não tinha dinheiro deixou
para depois a caixinha dois dias depois
pagou a faxineira atenção aqui você
autêntica com uma assinatura e aqui você
tava brincando com 2 natureza isso faz
parte do protocolo do acordo das pessoas
em seguida você tem pagamento do aluguel
e aí o diego que está sem emprego
pergunta pra alice e pro bruno
o chipset eu posso pegar um pouco desse
dinheiro sobrando cachorro é preciso
fazer pagar uma conta
estou precisando dinheiro eles autorizam
de novo o protocolo o protocolo aqui
caixinha alice bruno para tirar dinheiro
daqui a pouco bruto o diego descobriu
diego devolve 100 reais e ele mesmo se
eu tente imaginar que isso é que não
fosse um golpe e nisso é que seja um
ambiente em que as pessoas confiam entre
si funciona mas no momento que não tem
mais confiança entre diego alice e bruno
pode acontecer do dia dizer puxa vida
todo dia eu sumir com esse livro não
acontece com quem deixa eu
iraque e colocar 11 aqui na frente e
fingir que eu devolvi 1.100 não acontece
um toque
então esse é um exemplo muito simples
para entenderem os protocolos que vão
permitir que seja feito o lançamento e
avaliação dele ea perenidade desses
dados
então se nós tivéssemos aquela ideia que
todo este tempo mudar então vou pegar
todas as repúblicas de são paulo todo
mundo vai ter um único registro e vai
ser perene no bloquinho e ficar com uma
cara assim vários lançamentos e todos os
protocolos colocados aqui então você tem
os dados ea validação dos dados
como é que a gente usa isso para a nossa
realidade para aquele problema que a
gente tem que resolver tornar o mundo
mais sustentável
como eu faço pra que eu possa
minimamente acreditar no rótulo de
produto se suponhamos que eu tenho aqui
um chocolate e chocolate vem com a
seguinte em mensagem fabricado com cacau
colhido na costa da bahia sem devastação
da mata atlântica
você acreditaria você acreditaria
naquela alegação ele não traz prova
nenhuma
não importa a gente não tem opção mas
aos poucos nós vamos ter que acreditar
nessas alegações não apenas aquelas
ligadas ao sabor aos ao produto em si
mas aquelas alegações de propriedades
sociais que um produto traz consigo pode
ser feito hoje sim usando o blog em que
osmar contas lembre se que esses mais
contente e lhe dão transparência código
livre
qualquer pessoa sabe o que ele vai fazer
e ele é inevitável você não tem como
evitar que ele faça dessa forma se nós
tivéssemos aqui esse problema do
interesse o primeiro do consumidor saber
se é verdade ou não o que está sendo
dito
confrontado com o interesse da marca da
grande marca que criou aquele produto
aquela barra de chocolate especial fez
uma embalagem fez todo um
desenvolvimento à receita uma cadeia de
fornecedores fez um
marketing criou um produto aquilo ali
tem valor aquilo é protegido aquela
propriedade intelectual então ele também
está defendendo o interesse legítimo
como conciliar os legítimos interesses
do dono da receita quando o consumidor
através da transparência da confiança e
é isso que nós estamos conseguindo fazer
hoje no mundo inteiro e em particular a
cnaf deve ser hoje nós temos é um
diagrama bastante impactante mas contou
que que é uma moeda digital que você
pode transferir dentro do bloco em que
um fazendeiro quando vai escolher
aquelas 1.800 quilos de cacau pede que
venha uma autoridade alguém que o
consumidor na ponta vai acreditar seja a
universidade federal da bahia seja ela a
agroceres chega seja o greenpeace wikis
vai na minha fazenda e diz realmente
houve essa data esses 1.800 quilos de
cacau sendo colhido sem agredir a a a
mata atlântica e eu é certifico e wings
numa página da minha no meu site
essa página ela tem um link esse link
embutido em butiá aquela declaração de
amor dentro daquela naquela moeda
embutido aqui nesse top e o cacau quando
é vendido para a próxima processo aqui
no na cadeia ele é vendido pelo preço
internacional mais um plus porquê porque
é um caso especial ele prova que ele é
especial
então ele tem um incentivo para ser
propagado pela cadeia chegando aqui no
processador que é o que tem a receita
ele já tem a embalagem sabe que nesse
nessa barrinha que tem 18 gramas de
cacau
ele então pega o código de barras eo
lote aquele número então vai ser a chave
para que o consumidor possa acessar o
blog gene e capturar recuperar aquele
link do greenpeace
dessa forma a gente protege os
interesses do processador como também
protege o interesse legítimo do
consumidor de ter essa informação
por isso eu me sinto muito muito
orgulhoso e muito motivado pra fazer
parte dessa revolução e seu futuro
o consumidor consciente que através
desse tipo de tecnologia nós vamos
conseguir fazer com que os nossos netos
tenham um planeta mais saudável e mais
equilibrado eu conto com vocês muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]